autre édition d' espace autochtone en
direct je m'appelle le mari yvan on va
s'intéresser aujourd'hui aux 50 ans du
mouvement des centres d'amitié
autochtones
un mouvement qui regroupe plusieurs
centres à travers le québec des centres
d'amitié autochtone en fait il y en a
partout à travers le canada
mais on va s'intéresser à ceux qui sont
installés au québec avec nos invités je
vous les présente
on va commencer par le fond on va aller
voir la directrice générale du
regroupement des centres d'amitié
autochtones tania sirois bonjour quoi
bonjour bonjour également philippe meyer
qui est à montréal autochtone donc le
centre d'amitié 2 montréal philippe
meyer bonjour selon et isabelle picard
notre ethnologue et chroniqueuse en
résidence mais avant on va pas commencer
par ce sujet là si vous le voulez bien
on va parler d'un sujet d'actualité qui
fait la première page des espaces
autochtone aujourd'hui on parle encore
d'appropriation identitaire de la part
d'une personne qui s'appelle alexandra
l'oranje ils les chefs des communautés
particulièrement le chef de manawan
était un peu outré que quelqu'un
s'identifient comme attikameks alors
qu'ammann one elle n'est pas connu par
les gens de la communauté
finalement il ya eu des recherches qui
ont été faites des des historiens en
généalogie qui ont ont fouillé dans son
passé pour retrouver des ancêtres
autochtone qui remonte à très loin
j'aurais juste voulu avoir votre avis
là-dessus parce que ça arrive c'est
arrivé plusieurs fois au cours des
dernières semaines on a parlé de
marie-josée par an on a parlé de nadine
saint-louis maintenant alexandra
l'oranje qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais je me lasse ce sont tous des femmes
que je connais qui ont gravité dans le
milieu métropolitain
dans différentes instances différentes
organisations dans différents contextes
est ce que je déplore dans cette
situation là c'est que nous on est
essentiellement regroupement d'usb des
petites ou sbe dans certains cas des
peut-être plus grave mais on a une
capacité très limitée à des jeux livres
et les services qu'on a besoin de livrer
et on doit quand même avoir une
gouvernance autochtone on se présente
souvent comme un milieu
d'autodétermination autochtone passe pas
compliqué ce sont des autochtones sont
au ca
en majorité ce sont des autochtones sur
notre site à fort pouvoir parler de ce
défi là d'ailleurs prochainement et on
veut livrer à des personnes autochtones
mais dans un contexte historique en
étant sans égard au statut et c'est une
des choses très particulière des sondés
mythique on a toujours été sans statut
sans égard à ces questions là étant
donné qu' on était surtout des
emplacements initialement qui était
sécuritaire pour les autochtones pour
aller en ville
allez pour un rendez vous oui allez
aller chercher les opportunités qui sont
dans la ville que ce soit en éducation
en santé ou pour des emplois et
progressivement on ne passait de
simplement lieu de rencontre avec un
café et une coco qui vont nous
accueillir le perlage à des centres de
service à proprement dit qui ont
certaines ambitions de livraison
services et parmi tous ceux se réserve
en usb un peu partout le contexte
politique change il ya dix ans j'aurais
voulu faire avancer des certaines
thématiques pour mort et la salle arrêté
un poste les gens savaient même pas
qu'on existe et les autochtones n'était
pas sur le radar politique
il a fallu beaucoup de choses bougent
bien de gagner à draguer j'ai vécu la
crise due au contact des enfants et j'ai
vécu le post crise d'oka aussi et ça a
contribué à ma honte d'haïti autochtones
parce que partout où j'allais tout ce
que j'attendais c'est au-dessus des
armes chez toi rendez vous des
cigarettes
toutes les paires aberration que son
véhicule lire préjugés l'épée préjugés
et de tout à coup la politique a changé
la réconciliation est devenu quelque
chose il fallut une commission d'
enquête nationale avec plus de 7000
témoins pour dire que les pensionnaires
autochtone existait qu il ya eu un en
régime d'apartheid essentiellement et
naulleau basé sur
le passé culturel déjà et là tout à coup
on se réveille plus on commence à
investir de l'argent créé des
opportunités et des porteurs de projets
peuvent finalement avancé et on se
retourne dans un contexte où il ya des
gens qui ont été tolérés dans le passé
par des autochtones qui maintenant se
retrouvent identifié comme étant
d'ailleurs pas vraiment le niveau
d'autochtonie nécessaire pour pouvoir
s'investir dans des projets et c'est une
réalité qui est très complexe parce que
plusieurs d'entre nous dit ou pas assez
sexiste des lois sur le cheval à la loi
des indiens ont perdu leur statut ont
regagné leur statut les inuit bon s'ils
quittent leur territoire perdre leur
statut après dix ans
c'est extrêmement complexe de pouvoir
déterminer qu'est ce qu'on croit qui est
une personne auteur d'un hotspot à
l'angle des potes octobre moi je parle
comme à l'amour oui parce qu'on était de
cette française jeudi 8 octobre parce
que je parle pas pour certains citypass
autochtone apte à changer d'accent qui a
des décisions en ville des pubs vraiment
dynamiques sont différents c'est très
complexe est question là mais faut
qu'une tête ne tolérant envers des gens
qui n'ont pas suffisamment de
crédibilité
seysses parce qu'il faut laisser la
place aux personnes qui sont à
proprement dit dont qui ont une
expérience de vie autochtone et qui
prennent les rênes de nos projets mais
c'est une injustice
en plus des autorités koufos commencé à
trier les jeunes puis il faudrait mettre
des protocoles traditionnelle qui
existent pas le bo personne que jamais
eu a été confronté à ces réalités là
avant la colonisation
c'est très complexe fait quoi oui bah
oui tout à fait on le voit le lait les
dénonciations de la dernière année par
rapport aux gens qui se disaient
autochtone ou tout mois première nation
parce qu'on sait que le moteur tourne
peut être peut être mais trailer il
englobe métis inuits première exactement
et on sait que le mimétisme or et
énormément le dos large
également au québec en concile histoire
là isabelle pr nous disait
par rapport à la nation métisse de
l'ouest canadien oui et la monotonie et
le monde premières nations est petit ou
québec
donc on on le savait que certaines
personnes n'avaient pas leur statut
s'autoproclamait et tout ça
s'autoproclamait et c'est pour ça que je
trouve que c'est bien qu'on fasse
ressortir ça parce que on peut être un
allié
on peut être un allié dans les centres
des missiles il ya plein d'employés non
autochtone
il ya des départements qui contribuera à
ce qu'on réponde à notre mission mais ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut s'approprier
l'identité culturelle de la nation
je trouve que ça dans l'école philippe
disait dans les années 90 c'est d'être
pop
ce n'était pas populaire d'être des
premières nations que nous nous en
parler le moins possible j'ai tellement
milieu urbain et tout ça sur la côte
n'ont donc fait un phénomène qui est un
peu propres à montréal j'ai envie de
dire parce que avec les sens d'un petit
je suis à je suis porté à aller dans
différentes villes on va parler un petit
peu plus tard c'est sur cassette il
s'est moins tentant de s'autoproclamer
les gens se connaissent c'est un petit
milieu on connaît toutes les gens d'une
famille et tout ça donc c'est un
phénomène qui est principalement
montréal et isabelle mais en fait je me
suis déjà prononcés comme aurait fait
l'émission avec éric pouliot tisdale qui
était un des deux chercheurs le village
exactement mais en fait j'abonde un peu
dans le même sens on se connaît tous
si une question que je me suis fait
poser à maintes reprises quand j'étais
jeune dans ma communauté par les plus
vieux quand j'étais en france et c'est
qui ton parce qu'ils ta mère donc on
s'est donc soigner la finition donc ce
n'est quand même pas une surprise
maintenant est ce que tous ces gens là
qui se sont auto dénoncer ou qui ont été
dénoncées d'une manière ou d'une autre
ont fait ou mal leur je pense pas non
plus il faut quand même en prendre et en
laisser
puis-je abonde aussi dans le même sens
de philippe l'identité c'est un sujet
une définition qui est extrêmement
complexe notamment qu'on pense aux
adoptions coutumière traditionnel aussi
à la reconnaissance de la communauté
donc comment est-ce qu'on peut réussir à
dire oui lui il est autochtone il fait
partie est ce que c'est seulement par le
sens donc c'est toujours les mêmes
questions qui vont revenir
je pense qu'on devrait peut-être de plus
en plus justement voir comment on fait
les choses
ce qui me dérange c'est quand ces gens
leur vont prendre la place d'autochtones
qui étaient là justement dans les années
80 dans les années 90
et quand on mange et de la misère il ya
un fils quelqu'un sur facebook ce matin
de pessamit qui a dit mais ils étaient
où ces gens là quand on mange et de la
misère il y a personne dans les années
80 ou 90 qui voulaient se revendique
absolument absolument autochtone donc ça
peut être un peu plus d'erreurs qu'on
veut chercher des subventions des
bourses qui pourrait appartenir à des
gens qui en ont réellement besoin
effectivement ça pose un problème et
c'est ce qu'on voit d'ailleurs circulé
sur les réseaux sociaux là les
commentaires à l'article amène ses
différents aspects là certains parlent
d'une chasse aux sorties une chasse aux
sorcières est ce que c'est réellement
une chasse aux sorcières sans que ça
soit une chasse aux sorcières je crois
que les gens qui se sont eux que je vais
le dire comme ce lucky qui ont qui ont
pu gravité professionnellement ou via
des études à bien des études en
utilisent alors leur le fait qu'ils
étaient autochtone je crois que cela
aurait dénoncé cependant si tu étais
dans ton salon et une bonbonne d'une
sensibilité pour la culture autochtone
je ne crois pas c'est une chasse aux
sorcières
puis d'autant plus que ces gens là en
plus de bénéficier davantage au niveau
de bourse ou de postes ou quoi que ce
soit c'est toute la question de la
voiture on parle beaucoup de
d'autodétermination faut laisser la
place aux jeunes faut laisser la place
aux premières nations faut laisser la
place aux femmes
des premières nations inuits et mais
pour ça faut que les gens qu'ils ne sont
pas sept ans un peu parce que ça arrive
souvent que ces personnes qui se sont
déclarés ayant une identité autochtone
faisait la morale à même à d'autres
premières nations donc si ça fait
c'était le temps qu'on fasse ressortir
ça parce qu'il ya des gens qui en
bénéficient de davantage de rebondir
c'est vraiment mon expérience
personnelle des joueurs vivent les verts
je sors l'ami d'un ami qui a fait
comprendre tout ce jeu tales of est qu
évidemment ceux qui ont une mixité dans
leur génétique vivre toute la violence
latéral soit sur communauté ce que je
veux qu acheter enfin j'avais de la
troupe à ce moment pareil québécois vous
imaginez tikar sont plus à mon père et à
la détresse pas mal plus noir
les aixois la génétique c'est spécial et
c'est une réalité que on choisit pas
avec qui on tombe en amour il ya des
familles qui se crée simplement parfait
quant à sion et c'est une chose humain
puis les autochtones on a besoin de se
rendre réponse face à sow nous laissons
d'amitié on a une philosophie très
simple parce qu'on compose accès réalité
là en ville
tati déménager en ville tuer des hommes
des blooms pétrir de faire des enfants
avec des héritages mélanger aussi est ce
qu'on va dire non à la marque et
québécoises qui s'occupe de la fin
octobre désolé mais c'est juste le
parent qui peuvent venir au centre
évidemment c'est une famille nous qu'on
va soutenir parce qu'on va on veut
soutenir cet enfant là qui est tout le
de support qui pourrait avoir dans notre
contexte dans ma famille c'est vraiment
la loi sur les indiens avant 1985 c'est
une femme se marie marine est un homme
blanc elle avait son statut et voilà et
dans cette période là il n'y avait pas
nécessairement tout ce mouvement là
ah si on veut d'eux a dit que si on
était tous cependant fragile dans ces
moments-là fait que notre communauté à
le tourner combat grand mère elle
n'avait pu elle n'avait pas
nécessairement le soutien c'est quand
même aberrant bien sa leçon c'est eh ben
je m'arrangeais que mes enfants il ya
tous les moyens qu'il faut qu'ils vont
parler français puis ils vont sortir
s'il le faut avec ma famille c'est une
erreur famille moreau qui parle
francophone wii speak english
oui mais c'est une réalité c'est
seulement après les grands changements
législatifs qu'on a pu se réapproprier
nos droits et maintenant salle évolue
encore évidemment ça doit d un impact
sur des familles ces choses là si ces
détails là qui échappe aux gens que
c'est un contexte qui est vraiment en
mouvement après les changements
législatifs d'autres générations vont
grandir avec tous les droits qu'ils
devraient avoir
et on pourra composer ce que si mais
c'est très complexe étant donné qu'on
n'est pas non plus liée à des lois moi
si une personne qui vient de un état
américain
j'en ai eu des jeunes autochtones qui
venaient des états unis j'en ai une qui
vient de la meuse et l'on s'en va un
événement enfin seulement est-ce qu'on
veut lui dise non tepa première nation
de la confédération du canada t'es pas
su la loi sur les indiens non tête
autochtone tête autochtone on
t'accueille voilà merci on va boucler ce
dossier là pour aujourd'hui merci
d'avoir accepté de répondre à cette
question là là on va se pencher dans le
vif du sujet parce que il nous reste
trente minutes pour absolument passer à
travers ce que son ce qu'est le
mouvement des centres d'amitié
autochtones et ce qu'est le regroupement
parce que c'est un peu mêlant quand on y
connaît pas trop ce qu'on souligne cette
année dont de 2019 à 2020 finalement
c'est le 50e anniversaire du mouvement
des centres d'amitié autochtones en
soulignant la création du premier centre
d'amitié
donc c'était en 69 69 à chibougamau
c'est comme ça que le mouvement a pris
naissance finalement oui là le mouvement
le mouvement descendent m6 autochtone
c'est à commencer dans dans l'ouest du
pays
donc au québec on a été un petit we will
décès dans les années 50 que le
mouvement commencé dû justement à des
enjeux législatif les gens sont
principalement les femmes se
retrouvaient en milieu urbain les gens
quittent et les communautés pour aller
aux études de trouver un travail et les
gens voulaient se trouver à un endroit
où il se sentirait chez eux d'où le mot
semble d'amitié donc c'est commencer par
ça a commencé par un lieu de
rassemblement et on peut comprendre
qu'au cours des 60 dernières années
ça s'est transformée en la plus grande
infrastructure de services urbains pour
pour les autochtones au canada
donc on parle de près de 120 centres au
canada au québec on parle de trait
semble donc au québec comme ça a
commencé en 1969 qui divers différents
partenaires dont les nations la nation
crie qui qui ont voulu bâtir un centre à
chibougamau pour justement répondre à
des besoins c'était beaucoup des besoins
d'hébergement odile les cendres d'un
mythe il s'est vraiment les gens qui
venaient dans la ville qui venaient
recevoir des soins de santé tous avaient
besoin d'hébergement donc ça a commencé
ça et comme je vous dis ça fait que
depuis 50 ans maintenant donc leur 50e
anniversaire du mouvement au québec
louis fin de cette année et c'est ça le
mot clé en fait c'est urbain parce que
décent des meetings en a pas dans les
communautés autochtones ça se passe en
milieu urbain dont pour aller rejoindre
essayer de rassembler les autochtones
venus de partout parce que à montréal
vun accueillez pas que des premières
nations ce n'est pas que des mois c'est
des gens venus de partout venus de
partout
d'où la notion évidemment sans égard au
statut parce qu'on est là pour
accueillir
je pense est important pour des gens
comprennent que c'est aussi ici nous
versons plus sombre derrière tout seul
la ségrégation au québec salle existait
dans des règlements municipaux dans
certaines villes que je nommerai pas
parce qu'ils y ont changé certains
règlements il existait des règlements
que site est autochtone d'état en vue de
passer cinq heures du temps avant prison
prison municipale
on va aller parce que des chances que tu
brasses des choses je me gêne que
c'était ça la logique rassurer mais
c'était jusqu'à quand ça d'échangés
encore et encore parce que c'est
tellement début règlement que le temps
que ça passe mais ils sont plus
appliquées and on and on s'en fait
appliquer mais mais mais ils peuvent
exister bien évidemment plus imaginer
que si on a de l'art autochtone et qu'on
a une réserve pour trop loin que plein
de préjugés à propos de nous quand qu'on
va en ville
ben c'est du vrai ça me convient c'est
du tabassage c'est vraiment pas juste
qu'on est un petit lieu positifs et tout
ça on était en ses besoins d'une place
sécuritaire pour que les gens accèdent à
des opportunités qu'ils ont besoin et on
est encore ça aujourd'hui à des degrés
variables ya encore des villes où le
racisme est très préval en jeu cette
année il ya eu des jeunes qui ont été
tabassés d' encore une fois dans ce
musée renommé pour par bros et des
choses mais c'est une réalité au québec
ça va changer je me gêne un certain
temps mais dans le passé c'était extrême
oui alors on va mettre à table avec
isabelle en fait isabelle on va
expliquer un peu donc ce que sont ses
cendres mais vous avez aussi des
chiffres intéressants à nous présenter
usure sur les évidemment les premières
nations également des centres d'amitié
oui en fait ce que j'ai voulu faire
c'est un peu le portrait des autochtones
en réserve donc en communauté je pense
que c'est important pour placer les
choses donc dans la province de québec
on estime à plus de la moitié environ
55% des autochtones qui vont vivre hors
communauté au niveau des inuits environ
15% qui vont vivre hors du nunavik donc
ça c'est quand même et presque notamment
à montréal oui pour ce qui est des du
canada ses 66% qui vont vivre hors
communauté donc qu'il ya de plus
l'extérieur du québec
maintenant une statistique et j'ai
trouvé intéressante en 2016 plus de la
moitié des autochtones
or communautés vivaient dans une grande
ville
de plus de 30000 habitants donc sauf
quand même et c'est une augmentation de
60% par rapport à dix ans auparavant
donc 2006 mais j'imagine que si les gens
quittent les communautés ce n'est pas
pour aller s'installer dans un petit
village non plus mais c'est pourquoi
rien sous ses yeux pour le logement
l'emploi donc les principaux à nous on
avait fait une évaluation des besoins de
il ya quelques années déjà et les
principales raisons étaient les études
l'emploi la santé le on pourrait parler
du père mobilité je voulais parce qu'on
en parle mais on parle de 55% des
premières nations qui ont une adresse
permanent donc d'enlever donc mais on a
tout ce phénomène d'hyper mobilité ça
veut dire que c'est nécessairement les
gens qui quittent leur communauté c'est
des gens qui sont encore très normal
donc juste pour vous donner un exemple
on avait fait une étude dans une ville
et une communauté qui était qui était
avoisinantes et là l'individu pouvait
faire dans sa vie
jusqu'à cet aller retour donc on voit
les enjeux que ça peut apporter pas pour
l'individu mais pour sa famille les
enfants bon quitte l'école reprendre
l'école et tout ça donc l'hypermobilité
et là entre autres par rapport aux
premières nations également également
pour une recherche aussi on parlait de
de soins de santé
les gens qui quittent les clubs
nautiques sont un peu plus éloigné
harry dans les grands bancs les grands
centres la exemple si je prends un
exemple
bon ça y mener cette île où cadet des
centres régionaux au niveau des hôpitaux
qui est pas pour une journée ou deux
donc doivent être hospitalisés tout ça
donc il y à ces gens aussi que les 126
accompagne dans leur court séjour de 3
mois 2 6 - tout ça dans kick in qui se
passe dans leur vie oui on est vraiment
dans cet accompagnement vraiment une
grosse paire mobilité oui mais à trois
mois six mois mais les gens n'habite pas
au centre d'amitié de sentier n'est pas
là pour héberger des gens mais peut-être
à val-d'or et acheter des berges
transport médical cris oui à des
collaborations comme celle là qui se
font ici à montréal ils ont leurs
propres installations d'hébergement par
contre est-ce qu'on contribue à des
stratégies générales en matière de
sécurité publique
nous on sait morale autochtone siège au
comité classe pvm
il ya des projets qui sont là pour
justement assurer la sécurité des gens
qui sont racistes parce que la
problématique de l'itinérance ou cité
cause en grande partie à cause de ces
fameux service là et un accompagnement
qui était peut-être pas complet pour les
gens qui venaient évidemment lorient
c'est comme le chanvre l'europe pour
certaines personnes qui vivent dans des
communautés extrêmement éloignée avec
c'est vraiment incroyable bourde de
réussir à descendre en ville y ont
tellement d'opportunités que tout coûte
rien il ya des amis partout fait que
c'est assez intéressant de vouloir
rester plutôt que la retourner dans une
communauté de 200 personnes où tout
coûte 6 7 8 fois le prix y ont bien
amélioré les choses et on collabore avec
eux dans certains cas qu'un que les gens
décident de rester mais l'on peut
devenir en conséquence un lieu qui est
sécuritaire pour eux
pour accéder à des services les chiffres
que j'ai donné tout à l'heure les le
pourcentage
évidemment ça vient de statistique
canada mais ça c'est une auto
déclaration comment est-ce que c'est est
ce que c'est vraiment on a une idée du
portrait mais quels sont les vrais
chiffres avez-vous des études pour veine
on allait au niveau de 55 pour ça on
utilise
on a fait un portrait sur
l'accessibilité des services parce que
c'est un des gros enjeux là et on est en
recul est le plus grand d'échantillons
qui avait jamais été recueillis en
milieu urbain soit au dessus de 1700
répondant donc donc on n'a pas été en
mesure c'était vraiment au niveau du
portrait mais ce qu'on a été en mesure
de sortir comme donner c'est que il y
avait quand même 15 % et nous ont
demandé à premières nations et on allait
quelle nation et pour justement éviter
l'auto déclaration et on avait embauché
des sondeurs aussi pour justement le
stepper un recensement le kit eiffel
mais ce qu on a pu remarquer aussi puis
on parle 55 pour savoir s'il est vrai
est pauvre et y es tu sûr estimé
sous-estimé il y avait quand même il ya
la génération qui ne laisse en ville
moi je fais partie de cette général
aulaqi est né à baie comeau à 40 minutes
la communauté de ma mère donc savait pas
d'où je n'avais pas de lien que la
communauté mes grands-parents et ltz
donc il y avait quand même 15 % à 2723
répondant lui qui avait toujours résidé
en vue donc n'avait jamais résidents en
communauté donc ce chiffre risque de
s'accroître un peu plus grand mais à
savoir le vrai pourcentage c'est une
question extrêmement dur d'autant plus
haut niveau de l'hypermobilité qui on
aimerait ça les avons les chiffres parce
que quand on établit des programmes puis
quand on discute avec le gouvernement
fonctionne avec des chiffres et tout ça
donc on a d'autres façons de nos
statistiques on prend leur par rapport
au centre mais c'est sûr que rapidement
on s'est rendu compte que les stats au
niveau de stades canaux de vos dix
villes exemple à val-d'or conduit avec
700 800 premières nations dans la ville
qui conduisait mais mon dieu comment ce
que sont des outils il ya tellement de
voix évier donc c'est là qu'on a on a
travaillé avec avec des chercheurs sur
ce concept aux dates libres voulu
ajouter la recherche laisse est je pense
qu'on a dépassé ce stade de devoir
démontrer que des besoins pour les
autochtones
j'espère mais c'est jusqu'à maintenant
qu'il fallait encore le faire il va
falloir quand même continuer parce que
vos gouvernements changent constamment
il faut toujours rééduquer le prochain
gouvernement la prochaine administration
avec des faits pour appuyer le besoin en
financement pis ben je suis quand même
assez fier je suis aussi président du
regroupement dit que maintenant on est
un organisme de recherche à développer
cette filiale
parce qu'on veut plus être dépendant des
universités dépendant des chercheurs
parce que c'est une chose qu'on est con
on a horreur les personnes autochtones
cas qu'on attend je suis un
anthropologue je veux le faire une étude
sur votre communauté et l'on va jamais
entendre quoi que ce soit qui ont
déboursé choses là mais on n'est pas
fiers d'avoir maintenant cette capacité
on certain c'est tout nouveau ça fait un
an qu'on a cette filiale depuis on veut
la développer parce que pour faire du
hat veut que c'est pour faire du
plaidoyer pour faire du militantisme
il ya une partie qui est nécessaire
qu'il faut back up york times et qu'il
faut vraiment appuyer notre
mais force est capable de mesurer
l'impact des choses qu'on fait ça ça va
être le grand volet aussi qu'on va
développer
c'est bien de sortir des services de
faire des choses mais il faut trouver
les bons qu'ils ont vraiment dire oui
alors vous avez dit vous étiez le
président du regroupement vous êtes la
directrice générale du regroupement mais
là on part du mouvement ou si elle les
appelle je sais que vous avez pris des
notes là dessus c'est quoi la différence
entre le mouvement et le regroupement
mais je trouve que je suis la meilleure
personne
le mouvement c'est plus la partie un peu
plus abstraite sait comment tous les
centres fonctionnent dans l'ensemble
ainsi que tous nos partenaires et alliés
parce que le mouvement un mouvement
c'est vraiment dans la pensée des gens
c'est dans la culture des gens donc le
regroupement c'est un organisme pour
appuyer le mouvement des centres
d'amitié qui va offrir des services de
soutien de la recherche du militantisme
auprès des gouvernements et les centres
ensemble lorsqu'on travaille ensemble à
soit créé un regroupement à faire un
projet collectif ou à faire des
changements de société on s'entend
cédant au risque d'un conte travail on
peut parler du mouvement d'alors on ne
décide pas notre première planification
générale du mouvement plutôt que de
fortes indications stratégiques juste
pour notre groupe qui lui existe depuis
76 1976 alors que le mouvement est là en
fait avec l'arrivée du premier dont 60
exactement et à ce moment là il y avait
400 kg qui était qu'ils étaient vivants
le jodo qui avait été établie donc
d'enlever val d'or il y avait des becs
y'avait center y'avait chibougamau et là
dessus
j'avais oublié la tuque donc avant dans
les années soixante seize jusqu'à 80 et
ses centres ont voulu se créer une
association province à qui pourrait les
représenter qui pourrait à servir de
lieu de concertation de lieu d échanges
de bonnes pratiques et là est né le
regroupement des centres d'amitié donc
on est une association provinciale comme
il y a six autres associations
provinciales de 200 denti dans les
autres provinces
nos collègues donc il
des associations et regroupements et
dans les autres provinces prêt mais ce
ne sont pas tous les centres d'amitié
qui sont dans le regroupement
est ce qu'ils savent tous dans le
mouvement sont tous dans le mouvement
parce que le mouvement commun qu'on peut
voir ça c'est un petit peu quelque chose
qui est un legs de l'histoire chaque
personne qui a déjà travaillé pour un
100 m tickets déjà été bénévole dans un
centre d'amitié qui ont fait partie des
60 ans de c à c
des gens qui ont participé aux
mouvements récents donnent si la
majorité nous leader autochtone en soit
grandie des fois même dans un sens denti
où ils y ont contribué
donc pour moi ça c'est le mouvement
c'est cette espèce de chose un prêt
temporaire et certains centres ont pour
exceller raison non plus d'affiliation
par choix par obligation il ya toutes
sortes de environnement politique et
organisationnelle derrière tout ça des
différences d'opinion dans certains cas
mais par contre on appuie nous ne notre
philosophie c'est chaque organisme qui
est légitimement en mesure de desservir
des autochtones avec des services de
qualité ont leur raison d'être
on veut les appuyer dans tous les cas
c'est pour quoi que on va quand même
négocié nos choses semblent d'amitié
mais toujours avec une réflexion pour
dire mais tous les autres services aux
autochtones sont importants d'accord
j'ai une question à faire concrètement
peut-être pour les gens qui nous
regardent
c'est quoi qu'on fait dans ce sens
d'amitié de demain il ya beaucoup de
choses peuvent rapidement l'eau si je
veux acheter tout au niveau de la
persévérance scolaire donc la réussite
éducative donc ça peut être c'est
beaucoup de l'accompagnement puis du
soutien donc au delà d'avoir et je vais
vous donner des idées des domaines mais
on travaille pas si l'on travaille
vraiment là où tous les services se
construisent autour de la personne et de
la famille donc que ce soit des services
pour accompagner les étudiants les
services pour accompagner les parents
qui doivent avoir à faire avec l'école
de leurs enfants
que ça soit des services au niveau de
première ligne au niveau de soins de
santé et mieux-être
que ce soit des services de préparation
d'emploi des programmes de petite
enfance donc également ya dix ans ou qui
ont un sens de petite enfance donc un
cpe avait que de l'hébergement
le jeu j'en oublie pas taille mais tout
l'accompagnement soutiers puis des fois
ça peut être puis pour publier quand on
rentre dans un centre des missiles il ya
eu c'est pas comme rentrer dans un clsc
mourey a pris parce que souvent me
demande mais qu'est ce qui est
équivalent insolent démenti
parce que les gens ont besoin qu enfin
la vie cibc viser une énigme à ce que
les joueurs il faut sans arrêt au j'ai
un problème de toxicomanie pouvez vous
m'aider
ça se passe comme ça vous allez diriger
les accompagner vers les bonnes
ressources oui ou soit ils sont
accompagnés en même le centre d'amitié
mais tout tout réside dans le lien de
confiance
oui c'est ça qu'on essaie de travailler
très fort avec le réseau québécois de
faire comprendre que il doit avoir un
lien de confiance qui est établi pour
offrir ses services ce parce que les
gens ne fréquenteront polyservices de
les toqués des points sociétés ont le
documenter ça a été prouvé ou que les
autochtones sont très présents sais pas
où c'est l'essai c'est pas dans les
services de prévention
c'est via la police le palais de justice
et les prisons donc c'est pas normal que
la porte d'entrée pour pour avoir accès
aux services publics soit à ses services
donc dans un centre d'amitié en offre
tout ce que j'en ai sûrement oublié mais
juste pour vous dire le sait vraiment on
s'adapte aux besoins des gens sur le
terrain concrètement par exemple ok vous
parliez des services de première ligne
en santé je ne supporte octobre mais
mettons quelqu'un autant isabelle
isabelle arrive au centre d'amitié de
montréal qu'il ne s'appelle pas leçon
d'amitié qu'on expliquera un petit peu
plus tard à 10 ans j'ai tel problème
pouvez vous m'aider qu'est ce que vous
allez faire pour elle premièrement les
santons en géométrie variable
parce qu'ils sont tous autonomes et ont
tous des services en fonction de les
deux points de cette communauté de
papier donc dans par exemple montréal
autochtone a été créé dans une absence
de service pour enfin jeunes familles
diop beaucoup d'organisations
autochtones aux mots rien mais la vaste
majorité sont d'autres comme services de
première ligne services de crise
services pour des gens qui sont en
situation d'itinérance pif damas ce ne
sont pas des clientèles qui devront
mixité je pense pas du goût de famille
qui s'attendrait à voir en marge d'un
rôle de chanteur et un cpe oui bon
fait qu'on est là pour desservir une
certaine clientèle mais y'a pas à dire
qu'il irait vite car même dans nos
services parce que un autre grand besoin
maureilhan c'est la culture donc sig
quelque chose de beaucoup de jeunes qui
sont classe moyenne comme moi pizza bale
qui avait d'abord et à ne pas pour la
langue admettons qu'on a un énorme
programme au niveau des langues
autochtones et on a moins de services
d'irak en matière de santé parce qu'à
montréal
4 si ça c'est sa yo des clsc sur tout
les coins de rue et nous manque quelques
on a fait une arme à ping sont dans
toutes les armes seront une douzaine une
vingtaine ou une trentaine une centaine
devant toutes les autres
oui donc faire des points centralisée
c'est pas nécessairement solution pour
tout laisser à bâbord
il ya un service de liaisons médical ou
c'est une porte d'entrée avec une
infirmière qui peut jouer un rôle
préventif d'intervention mais une fois
que sa revente dans l'intervention
spécialisée dans l'accompagnement
spécialisé meilleur un corridor de
services dirais qu'avec un seul essai
pour peu qu'on perde d'autant qu'ils
condamnent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment que ça
fonctionne et c'est un modèle qu'on veut
répartir un peu dans les centres je
finis rendirent ma vulgarisation qu'est
ce qu'on fait c'est deux choses ont fait
essentiellement oui de l'accompagnement
qui le volet psychosocial pour
accompagner les gens dans leurs
objectifs de vie mais l'autre grand
chose qu'on fait c'est vraiment tout le
côté enseignement enseignements des
compétences enseignement des langues
enseignements traditionnels et en tout
ça le côté social fort des événements
communautaires pour construire assembler
qu'on a des lieux juste juste flâner ou
restée aux simples pour certaines
personnes c'est ce qu'ils ont besoin
oui oui mais refait en faisant mes
recherches je disais que dans les années
50-60 dans l'ouest canadien
c'était c'était un instant de
sécurisation culturel c'était le seul
endroit dans la ville où il pouvait
s'épanouir culturellement
je sais pas moi faire d'irriguer les
eaux d'enfer à faire des cours de danse
de porc ou à faire du père la gta et à
travers ça il faut mesurer ce que je me
trompe mais c'est là qu'on pouvait
identifier les besoins des gens donc
peut-être en santé mentale ou peut-être
un support par rapport aux enfants chez
terra donc c'est un lieu de passage qui
est absolument nécessaire et est
extraordinaire
on n'est pas des centres de crise mais
évidemment cas qu'on connaît le centre
c'est un peu notre modèle acheté aller
pour des activités sociales j'aime le
monde la bonne connais sont comme moi
quand ça va pas bien qu'il soit allé
voir avec mon et en plus souvent pris
dans cette réalité-là plus observateurs
belhoste personnel at elle besoin de
plus d'appartements ses enfants qui vont
les aider avec leur souvent nos équipes
vont comme un peu improvisé des
solutions oui et là on est rendu dans
les sens des missiles 2.0 on va avoir la
capacité de répondre à ça même si c'est
quelque chose qui est relativement
ponctuelles dans l'année dans l'absence
on est désorganisée dans les services
les cieux sont pas capables de répondre
nécessairement parce qu'ils sont pas
culturellement pertinents et là on est
vraiment rangé à comprendre qu' on a un
rôle important
faut nous appuyer pour le bas sinon les
gens tombent dans les craques
désormais alors le budget du québec sera
déposée le 10 mars
en décembre dernier la ministre des
affaires autochtones du québec madame
d'amour avait un peu mis de côté les
chefs et s'était dit ben moi je vais
m'adresser directement au centre
d'amitié autochtone je vais travailler
avec eux pour implanter des services
elle a pensé aux femmes aux enfants et
tous at-elle bien agi en se tournant
directement vers les centres d'amitié et
qu'attendez vous d'elle
non aucune précision à farges juste à
dire tout le monde était au tour de la
première table pour la commission
viennent oui nous on a un travail
phénoménal pour gratter des scènes pour
réussir la montée descente puis ça fait
des années qu'on pense à nos stratégies
pour dire on peut te leur démontrer que
des besoins comme en conférant vendredi
le maire un groupe de recherche
tellement que c'est nécessaire d'appuyer
nous dit parce qu'on n'est pas écoutée
par les gouvernements on n'est pas
entendu où on se fait donner des
pinottes avec du financement annuel qui
offrent aucune stabilité pour créer des
expertises fait qu'on se prépare depuis
longtemps et quand la crise a débuté à
val d'or c'était qu'elle l'organisme qui
était au centre de tout ça le sens d'un
site valdes évidemment c'est sur notre
radar et ça fait depuis le début qu'on
se dit donc on va proposer un grand
portrait pour démontrer qu est ce qui se
passe dans un service public et on va
faire valoriser nos centres les plus
forts des modèles les plus fort applaudi
donnez nous les moyens dans tous les
à géométrie variable de répondre comme
le sens de val d'or pourrait faire
passer pas toutes les ombres qui
pourrait faire ce qu'on avait les
demandes
on était prête puis on a approché la
ministre automatiquement et on a proposé
quelque chose puisqu'elle l'a fait au
niveau des chefs les médias de cette
erreur ça lui appartient
oui et nous notre travail c'est de
travailler notre filière et de
développer des services dans l'absence
dans certains cas de soutien politique
qu'on aimerait bien avoir de la part de
nos chefs et qu'on aimerait bien avoir
de la part de tous parce que c'est un
travail extrêmement difficile de
développer un sens d'amitié on se fait
piquer de l'argent on travaille pour
chaque scène je pense que c'est
important
ben quoi rajouter après après ce propos
de philippe effectivement nous on était
prêts parce qu'on est là là là ça fait
longtemps qu'on documente les besoins
dans les centres d'amitié
on sait qu'à descendre des mythiques
sont un peu plus gros il y en a qui sont
en consolidation présentement
donc nous on était prêt à savoir nos
besoins nouveaux d'infrastructures nos
stratégies nous on travaille sur des
stratégies au niveau du mieux-être
globale au niveau de la justice et
sécurité publique et juste pour vous
donner un exemple la justice toute la
notion de d'accessibilité à d'avoir de
l'accompagnement de raconter dans le
système judiciaire passé les femmes
c'est les hommes c'est des familles je
rentrerai pas dans le dossier de la dpj
la mémé mais ça ça avait passé un petit
peu sous le radar c'est dans les
dernières années en s'assoyant avec les
intervenants des centres d'optique on a
dit ok il ya vraiment un manque parce
que les centres d'amitié
c'est malheureux mais c'est bon en même
temps et c'est comme il dit ils font ils
le font tout simplement ils diront peau
non moi je t'accompagne potes à des
problèmes avec palais de justice et tout
ça donc c'est naturel c'est la
solidarité ça fait partie de nos valeurs
et tout ça donc on avait de la misère
dans les dernières années on peut dire
avoir les cinq six dernières années à
dire mais qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce
qu'on est réellement qu'est ce qu'on
fait quand on fait un peu de tout donc
on est vraiment la daf en train de se
construire des stratégies et c'est ce
que nous avons déposé au gouvernement du
québec
si ce qu'on travaille depuis des années
vous ça date pas d'hier non plus notre
relation avec le gouvernement provincial
donc 40% à peu près de votre vie
j'ai vient du gouvernement exactement
exactement en 2006 là il ya eu vraiment
des ententes
c'est sûr que c'était pas encore là
c'était pas des gros en temps mais l'on
travaille vraiment faire reconnaître
parce qu'on se disait toujours auquel
pas d'ambiguïté juridictionnelle
c'est dans les villes mais souvent des
victimes de droit de dire premier
fédéral
les premières nations c'est fédéral
d'adopter et là à cause de ton ne
répondait pas aux besoins dans les
villes jusqu'à tac effectivement des
événements malheureux sont arrivés et le
gouvernement du québec a eu une prise de
conscience de dire ok il ya des
autochtones en milieu urbain et ils sont
sur le territoire de la province donc on
se doit de de leur offrir les meilleurs
services possibles et une des portes des
meilleurs de d'offrir de meilleurs
services possibles c'est les centres
d'amitié
oui donc c'est vraiment dans cette
optique là que que qu'on travaille nous
on est des d une organisation de
prestations de services
il ya des enjeux politiques qui sont
négociées à un autre niveau mais nous on
situe vraiment organisations de services
qui travaillent pour les besoins terrain
et rousseau et dans le respect des
autres organisations
alors espérez vous que votre enveloppe
va être bonifié le 10 mars
ben on espère parce qu'on a travaillé on
espère puis on essaie de sensibiliser le
plus en plus le non seulement au niveau
politique mais au niveau aussi des de
l'administratif de voir comment qu'on
fait la différence et ça on en parlait
en tout comme un conte peut mesurer
l'impact social donc on travaille
présentement sur une recherche qui qui
voit qu'ils vont nous dire c'est quoi le
coût de l'inaction
parce que l'inaction pour moi c'est une
forme de discrimination de racisme on
n'a pas parlé beaucoup mais ne pas agir
moi je trouve que c'est très grave donc
donc cesser de voir comment qu'on peut
justement à construire on parlait de
pont de porte d'entrée tout ça entre le
réseau public parce qu'on se repose et
palais de justice demain matin saint
densi on opère au point qu on va le
suivre le gréement à l'extrême mais
c'est de démontrer que cependant de la
confiance des gens est quelqu'un qui est
banal en est allé directement à
l'hôpital c'est aussi le choix de lundi
oui parce que les centres d'amitié
servent à ça aussi de donner le pouvoir
d'expression aux gens on a des conseils
d'administration on est des instances
démocratiques
donc on ose espérer que les gens
s'impliquent dans les centres des multi
tant au niveau de la gouvernance de
bénévolat et tout ça pour justement
qu'on conçoit au fil de nos devoirs
comme comme je vous dis comme citoyen
tottenham l'obligation de devoir et je
trouve que le devoir d'être informé de
s'impliquer de revendiquer quelquefois
donc je trouve que je trouve que les
cendres et même si son temps un bout
beaulieu pour ça il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui maintenant le monde est beau
mais type se sont épanouis ils se sont
épanouis mais on espère que notre
contribution
oui elle répond à des services de
première ligne de 10 des besoins le
imminent mais ou s'ils peuvent répondre
les jeunes qui n'ont pas nécessairement
dans danger ou des adultes peuvent
trouver au sein du tandem c'est vraiment
un lieu d'expression sociale actuelle
israël identitaire et tout ce we alors
on est à montréal est là il faut
absolument expliqué au coin de la rue
saint-laurent et de la rue ontario ya un
centre d'amitié autochtone
ce n'est pas votre sens puisque votre
centre s'appelle montréal autochtone il
est situé ailleurs plus près du marché
atwater
c'est quoi la différence entre les deux
la différence entre les deux sens
d'amitié autochtone c'est un peu
l'ancien sens si on veut puis a été
créée dans les années 80 opérations ils
ont existé dans côte-des-neiges ensuite
ils ont une infrastructure qui était une
contribution d'une banque se sont
déplacés naturellement un peu l'équipe
qui était là devait répondre à une
clientèle différente
c'était plus des itinérances wheeler
modèle de faire varier aussi pour ce qui
est de la filiation
une réalité que les gens doivent
comprendre même si on est des lieux
d'autodétermination ça vient avec des
forces et ça vient avec des risques et
en matière de gouvernance nocera sont
vulnérables évidemment à la bonne
gouvernance ou la mauvaise gestion et
des défis de politique d'idéologie des
différences d'opinion sur certaines
enveloppes on est constamment en train
de débattre
qu'est ce que c'est le mouvement des
sans d'amitié au c ur du regroupement et
yves de maillots des personnalités qui
peuvent choquer
faisait pas partie de ces choses là mais
ça veut pas dire que dans les
communautés non plus on s'entend pas
tous à entre les nations sentant potter
et dans les centres d'amitié ce sont des
organismes du mali et dans certains cas
il ya des désaffiliation qui peuvent se
passer
les anciennement le rôle du regroupement
c'est tout mettre en oeuvre pour que
l'on ait des relations structurantes
positive parce qu'on est vraiment sous
pression des doigts et un peu pour
boucler la boucle du centre de manga
parce qu'effectivement c'est une
question qui nous revient constamment
faut comprendre aussi que cette
organisation le porter le nom sont des
missiles autochtones depuis des années
donc ont peu fait pour et ils ont leur
raison d'être ça c'est sûr mais se borne
à la lan
la mission d'un centre d'amitié
autochtone et elle est régie aussi bien
aux notes association nationale donc
donc c'était d'offrir des services là
plusieurs plusieurs plusieurs personnes
que ça soit temps de vous des
différences niveau de la dette d'aider
famille et tout ça ait eu un bon pour
différentes raisons et je respecte leur
choix se sont concentrés le sueur sur un
sursaut ce sont des gens qui ont des
grands besoins
cependant contrairement aux deux au
centre comme qui sont pas affiliés au
regroupement laissant que son pavillon
rue marionnettes de viana 2
une somme en de l'association nationale
donc ils sont reconnus comme s'endette
c'est juste le nom à ce moment là qui
qui qui jouent des petits tours par
rapport à ça mais je crois que marianne
autochtone vous avez des partenariats
avec copie ils ont leur raison d'être
parce que je crois que montréal en
raison d'avoir plusieurs organisations
mais oui que toronto ventes repartiront
pas là il est malin n'est pas chez vous
roberval donc ou que restant des métiers
le seul le seul acteur oui oui on vient
juste d'embaucher une gestionnaire de
prévention peuvent aller rencontrer le
monde respire gauche il ya des histoires
qui reste il ya des choses qui se
passent dans la vie des organisations
mais ultime en nous notre relation s'est
tant qu'on peut travailler pour notre
monde oui on va toujours ça c'est
vraiment ce qu'ils veulent c'est ce qui
primerait pour travailler pour que ça
serve sur le terrain et le regroupement
un peu c'est son rôle aussi parce que en
train
on travaille justement je paie des
parents parlaient d'une planification
stratégique du mouvement et on a des
grands enjeux au niveau de rechercher la
relève parce que la main d'oeuvre est de
plus en plus rares donc on privilégie
c'est sur une main-d'oeuvre aussi
premières nations il nous est donc
encore plus rare et aussi on a tout ce
besoin là parce qu'on le disait les
besoins sont de plus en plus nombreux
dans les villes de plus en plus complexe
d'équivoques infrastructure de services
puissent avoir les moyens de suivre
cette réalité l'horreur donc on est on
est vraiment dans des beaux projets au
niveau de la professionnalisation des
équipes dans les centres des missions
part de plus de 200 personnes qui
gravitent dans les employés du mouvement
des centres d'amitié au québec
majoritairement des femmes je crois
qu'il faut le dire c'est un milieu qui
offre des des emplois de qualité à des
femmes autochtones et leur permettent
justement de contribuer au mieux-être de
nos communautés
donc on est vraiment dans ses défilés
des défis de formation et tout ça pour
niveler par le haut moi je trouve que le
milieu autres acteurs méritent de pau
niveler vers le beau aimer d'avoir les
meilleurs services possibles et c'est
vraiment dans cette optique là que le
mouvement au québec on s'est doté de
moyens et tout ça deux processus pour en
arriver là
maintenant on a besoin d'un petit coup
de main au niveau des gouvernements et
c'est ce qu'on vaut boire bat avec le 10
mars prochain
voilà il se sera le mot de la fin parce
que le temps file merci beaucoup à tous
les trois y avait encore un million de
questions à poser mais vous reviendrez
éventuellement tania sirois donc
directrice générale du regroupement des
centres d'amitié autochtones du québec
philippe meyer présidente ce
regroupement
et puis directeur général du montréal
autochtone et isabelle picard acquis
jeudi à la semaine prochaine ou bien
sont merci à vous tous d'avoir été là
encore une fois si vous avez des
questions des commentaires vous allez
sur notre page facebook ne vous gênez
pas pour pour faire ses commentaires
pour écrire ces questions et je vous dis
à la semaine prochaine au revoir
[Musique]